there may not be a bigger rivalry in
American pro sports than the one between
the New York Yankees and the Boston Red
Sox the Major League Baseball Titans
have been clashing since 1901 meeting
for more than 2,200 games but today
they're taking it to a brand-new venue
the team's will meet at London Stadium
in just a few hours it will be the first
ever major league game played in Europe
and the first time the Yankees and Red
Sox play each other on artificial turf
Ian Lee is there with more Ian good
morning good morning as you said it's
taken over a century to get here Red Sox
versus Yankees in London and with more
than 55,000 fans expected at today's
game it's taken weeks to prepare
there's no rooting for the home team
here Yankees and Red Sox bringing their
classic rivalry to new grounds in London
getting a chance to see the first game
in Euro that's gonna be something
special and you know we want to make it
an enjoyable experience for the fans the
chance to show the world what baseball
is all about and obviously our rivalry
and having two of the best teams in
baseball here it's a big deal but
delivering this big deal to the UK was
no walk in the ballpark it took three
weeks to transform this soccer field
rolling out a hundred and forty thousand
square feet of synthetic turf a first
for the two teams but at least the
infield dirt will feel familiar 540 tons
shipped in from slippery rock
Pennsylvania even Yankees superfan Spike
Lee flew in for the game I think that a
lot of people can enjoy the game not
even knowing the
is gonna be festive he's gonna be a lot
of noise hopefully London will adopt the
Yankees other fans didn't have to travel
too far to be here all weekend it's a
dream come true
bringing their unique British flair to
America's favorite pastime and it's
striking that chord with Brits MLB
commissioner Rob Manfred says could be
the future of baseball I think it's
important to kind of put your best foot
forward
these two teams give us a unique
opportunity to create buzz surrounding
the game an opportunity to win some new
fans for the old ball game despite who
wins today's game Major League Baseball
hopes their first impression across the
pond is a home run
Jeff there you go ok Ian thank you very
much all right so the Yankees and Red
Sox have played in total in the regular
season 2262 times Michelle likes it
because the is running that overall
series 1000 that's why you like it
187 games regular season we were so we
were talking about why the dirt why they
had to bring the dirt in and I there's
not an exact reason other than they did
this in Tokyo also and the idea that you
want to have something that feels like
what you are used to so it's the clay
and the dirt and the way it makes well
I've got two sports people here you're
gonna be watching every pitch Michelle
no